we know that everyone has been eager to
see starfield yep our show
has highlighted game play
so it's only fitting that we end it with
an extended first look let's deal with
the most anticipated games in xbox
history i'm so curious what this is
going to look like is star field
let's go all right
it's happening xbox console exclusive
starship frontier
[Laughter]
and they still haven't changed
has converged
auxiliary
let me see the game
[Music]
grateful there's no way spending the
time there's no way we waited a long
time to finally see
star field you're jokingly our most
ambitious game ever like our previous
games it's an epic role-playing game
there's got to be more than that there's
no way this time you'll be exploring
space
so let's jump right in okay in the game
[ __ ] hell
thank god
it's like a todd howard jump scare jesus
okay
oh man can you imagine phil said
extended
[Laughter]
oh god okay i apologize todd
you've always put on great conferences
in my opinion you've got it
apologize
you telling me this is gameplay
well that looks like
[Music]
okay according to the scanners the
abandoned research facility is in this
direction we got that uh fallout 3 ugly
green kind of tint but i imagine that's
just this planet
[Music]
that's quite pretty there's a lot of uh
density i wonder if you can really go
all that way
that's a big border
oh
you spoke away
okay
it has immediately occurred to me that
this is probably going to be a lot more
like fallout than
i had maybe previously considered
okay
that's no man's sky
type business
which works well with like the
more crafty direction for that
forwarding
it's not like it looks like fallout it
look it definitely looks better than
fallout but um
the skyrim and space comparisons were
all up here it's more fall out of the
space crimson fleet or using the
facility
i like to look at the ui
i actually um
oh i'm probably in a minority where i
prefer fallout 2
elder scrolls
so i'm cool with it
the combat looks a lot tighter than
previous fallout
so far
definitely
looks like an upgrade on the on the
fps
which is like part of why everybody used
vats in fallout right it's like that
they
it's never that satisfying whereas
of course gotta have your lockpicks it's
a better game
the lack of cross hair is confusing my
brain
[Music]
i hope we get to see more planets like
i'm not loving the way it looks it's all
after some initial encounters you're
invited to join constellation who in the
future the game is set in are the last
group of space explorers to meet them
you'll head to the capital city of new
atlantis
okay i would like to see a city
this looks very mass effect
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to constellation we have a lot
to talk about
it's so weird that my brain keeps
drawing parallels to committed to the
biggest questions out of worlds
because it's obsidian what's
out there that's pretty
these artifacts could be everything
we've been looking for
i really hope we get some good planet
variety what they're building and it's
not just um or wastelanding
you will be partially solving that
puzzle now
so you found something the new guy found
it
you dug up the artifact right that means
you saw it the visions
the artifact you found appears to be one
of many
scattered across
if
of course the settle systems is full of
groups with other priorities it's kind
of disappointing that they all appear to
be human
everybody get ready
to be human
agree to work for uc system together you
take down those
when you sign up with a crimson fleet
no one quits
the only way out
is death again all this is very out of
world
oh that was cool
that is not cool
most dusty's don't even make it this far
because whatever lies at the end that's
pretty
very no man's sky
forever
that gives you a look at the stories in
star field
but ultimately it's not our story it's
the story you create by who you are and
the choices you make and that starts
with character creation
hell yeah give people what they want
it's our most flexible yet
you can customize all the elements of
how you look
[Music]
you've
says here you spend some time as a
diplomat having a way with words might
prove useful
their faces do look a lot better than in
previous games
[Music]
the best from our previous games that's
a nice layout you can unlock new skills
as you level up and then you rank those
skills up by using them and completing
challenges
and there's deep crafting systems from
running research projects with resources
you find
to crafting weapon mods if needed to
survive
yeah the the combat definitely looks
better
and you can build your own outposts
these act as a home away from home for
survival and resource generation
i'm gonna have a good time where and how
to build each one
and you can hire characters you meet to
keep it up and running
but that's not all
you can even build your own spaceships
okay
not what i expected
the interior is cool
you can choose crew members
and yes you can completely customize the
look and layout wow
there's loads of different modules ship
manufacturers and more
i have to say it's so cool we just
absolutely love this
that's very cool that is very cool it's
not just how the ship looks it's how it
performs yeah engines to shields to
weapon systems can we fly because yes or
is that animation you can fly it woohoo
front stairs
oh cool
that looks beautiful
damn
[Music]
i don't know what they do about like
gravitational pulls in the planets or
anything like that
this looks rad
damn
that's awesome
[Music]
this looks so
so so so cool i'm so impressed by this
especially like it looks like such a
different game to the stuff that's
actually on the planet
we can't wait
for all of you to experience the game
thanks again for being with us today and
thanks for all the support you've given
us over the decades especially on this
game no worries todd it's been an
incredible journey for us making it but
we know
that's really only the beginning for
it's when all of you play it that the
real journey begins
and you may be wondering just how big is
this game
so we thought we'd take one last moment
and show you
let's take a look at one of our planets
jemisin
you can land in new atlantis
but you can also land and explore
anywhere on the planet
you can land anywhere not just this
planet it's all the planets in the
system
from
resource heavy ice balls
to goldilocks planets with life
and not just this system
but over a hundred systems
over one thousand planets
all open for you to explore damn we
can't wait
to see what you find that's nuts
holy [ __ ] how is that even gonna run
wow
that's very very very impressive
it's gonna be a massive video game
and there's that uh location variety of
santa
[Music]
planets all look a lot more earth-like
than i
would have thought
dude wow
wow i wonder if that'll put a huge fire
under star
[Music]
doing a lot of citizen's
same [ __ ] and it's coming out
i wonder if i have to delay again
damn man that is
nuts
i feel like i went on so many like
roller coasters of how i felt throughout
that whole
presentation of things being like eh
that looks okay to like holy crap what